Enabling auto tracking on all activities
is a quick way to get started
with Google Analytics, but
it's not always the best approach.
You should think about what data
you really want to track, and
code your app to track the data
that's important to you.
In this lesson, we look at how to
track data about what your users do
by sending specific screen and
event hits.
We'll look into tracking goals to see if
users are completing the app objectives.
We'll delve into tracking
Ecommerce there to see if users
are spending money.
And then we'll take a quick look
at how to send timing data, and
how to track crashes and exceptions.
We'll finish the lesson with
a discussion of tracking how users
download your app.
It's always good to know.